hello like oh did I fall asleep for a
little while are we ever going to see
what's in the Attic
yes yes I'm not going to tell you now
what you're going to see but yes we will
to be taking a trip to the Attic this
season okay so we're going to see some
of these important characters I like are
they going to come out of the Attic no
we're going to visit the Attic and yes
we're going to see some girlfriends but
and yes we're going to see what so so
the next season is that is it going to
be about like the origins of dogs
differently see some of the the past
at the same time we're gonna be moving
forward and not spent the whole time
this retreads and it'll always and show
that to inform what's going to happen
later on and just keep on holding all
the characters I've been learning about
their past so seeing things about that
we didn't never expected and they're all
adults Oh such a neat spoiler and that's
on furnishings what's the big bad coming
for the next season that's interesting
we have a big bed I can't tell you about
it's all I can say is it's it's somebody
that echo has a history with she may not
know
and I'm not being coy I don't know so
cookies eat them up